I like a bit of nostalgic TV I like
being reminded of the good old days when
I was younger and my knees still worked
I like it to a point
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV a
movie channel
[Music]
I get a lot of comments on this channel
whenever we talk about a hard reboot a
continuation a soft reboot whatever
from people basically saying for the
love of God why can't they just do
something new and then when something
new is done people go no it's not as
good as that old thing I liked
so executives are the big streaming
platforms have this problem how do they
get people to watch the TV show that
they've spent hundreds of millions of
dollars producing
one easy way is to do something that
people already like or remind them at
least of something they already like
that is an easy way to get bums in seats
it's an easy way to get a bit of
Interest around the project that you're
doing even if it is a completely new
project if it's made by somebody that
made something you like you'll notice
that that gets pushed a lot The Arc
recently from the creators of Stargate
from the creators of Stargate plastered
all over it
so Nostalgia works
Picard season 3 was a Nostalgia Fest it
was very much a show completely with the
fans in mind Taylor had basically
listened to all of the complaints about
Star Trek over the last few years and he
wrote a TV series for the fans it was
Dripping with Nostalgia from everything
from the build up to the Enterprise D
being unveiled even though we knew that
was going to happen in every episode
there was at least one two maybe three
moments that were purely aimed at
Nostalgia at reminding us about the
Golden Age of Star Trek when TNG was on
and we were all happy and trekkies were
United in the love and admiration for
this TV show God I remember the good old
days when trekkies were United
not anymore
so Executives like to do these nostalgic
moments now I find them a little bit
irritating at times because we always
have to have those shots within the
episode when the actor although whatever
it is a set or something is
um revealed that it's supposed to be
nostalgic and it's supposed to remind us
of those good old days so it'll be an
active so it'll be that long sweeping
shot where you see this back of the
actor's head and we all know it's about
to happen but then we're still supposed
to go when it's revealed that yes it's
data or it's Ensign row or it's whatever
whatever is there supposed to be
revealing that's supposed to be such a
shock that nowadays never is because we
always know about it beforehand or the
actual command and then there's almost
like pause that two or three seconds
like a pause for a pause sort of thing
and where we're supposed to just have
that moment of oh my God it's that
person I like from that thing
um and those sort of shots really do
feel out dated nowadays because as I
said because of leaks because of
actually a lot of the time Executives
telling us beforehand because they want
clicks or we know it's going to happen
they can't really surprise us anymore so
why do Executives do it why do they love
nostalgia well psychologically we like
Nostalgia we like to be reminded about
our youth there's actually a thing in
Psychology called sort of like the
Goldilocks are and there's a period in
your life and it's roughly 16 to 25 when
everything was just better and people
look back and think oh the good old days
and nothing life gets better every year
you know um I think actually we're much
wealthier than we were back in the 80s
and the 90s we have Internet and mobile
phones and all of these brilliant
marvelous Technologies but I still look
back at that time nostalgically go
mainly because like I say my knees
worked but
music was better that time and just
everything else and we all have that
little golden period in our life so we
just think everything was better
filmmakers like to remind us of that
because like as I said it puts bombs in
seats but they also do for a few other
reasons some positive and some negative
for example
in a positive way when they're doing a
reboot or a new series The Creator might
actually really love what came before so
say you're doing a new Stargate movie
and you adored sg1
if as a Creator as a writer as a
director you're going to want to give
sg1 a little bit of a nod now they do
this in lots of movies and they'd like
to do that and it's these little things
that pop up and they just remind us of
the original like the original actor
coming back for something in a different
role say or um in the Dungeons and
Dragons movie recently they did a little
nod to the cartoon where the um Chris
Pine and everybody's running around and
they run into and they see the Caged
characters basically from the cartoon
series it's a very funny moment it's a
little nod back to something the Creator
actually really loved in the cartoon
that I adored as well so sometimes it's
done out of respect sometimes it's done
simply duplicate fans
they're doing something new they know
it's going to annoy certain elements of
the fan base so they bring something
back from the original just to try to
appease them to try to get everyone to
calm down a bit so it is done very much
as a tactic as a technique to sort of
try to calm a lot of the fans down but
also just appease them just to remind
them yes we do respect drop came before
honest and we are thinking about you so
sometimes it's done with the fans in
mind as a bit of a psychological
technique if you like to calm us all
down a little bit and I actually don't
think that's a bad thing
I do think it's a bad thing when
creators just do it to get clicks on
social media now this is something that
I've argued when talking about a few
other things like when a character gets
gender swapped for example now talk
about Battlestar Galactica again I will
always argue that turning
um star book into a lady and Katie
Sackhoff in particular because she was
amazing in it was actually done for the
best reasons I actually saw an interview
at the time with creators sort of saying
that look this character is boring we
needed to do something a bit more
interesting with it Kirk Benedict was
really amazing in this originally and we
needed somebody else that stood out in a
similar way we just didn't think we
could do it with a man
it made it more interesting for us to
make her a woman so I was completely on
board with that I think it worked
brilliantly
sometimes though they gender swap
characters Etc just to get clicks to
make people angry to get clicks to try
and build up a bit of Interest now I
actually think that they do that with
Nostalgia as well they bring back actors
or they bring back certain elements of a
previous TV show just to get clicks
it has nothing to do with the series
they're doing it has nothing to do with
the movie it's just to get a little bit
of interest to get people talking I
actually think that's a complete waste
of time and really they shouldn't bother
if what you're doing isn't a nod to the
previous show out of respect or doesn't
actually do something for the project
you're doing say for example the new
Quantum Leap series it's going to heart
back and reference the old series quite
a bit because it's a sort of a
continuation it's necessary for the
story it's not really just mention it
out of nostalgia it's mentioned because
it's needed to explain what they're
doing now that is also brilliant and
absolutely fine so throwing in Nostalgia
into a show is really a lot like a
reboot itself
sometimes it's done brilliantly
sometimes it's done because somebody's
got a really good idea on how to
continue something we like and yes fair
enough the executives will go right this
is a safer bet we like safer bets let's
go with that
but sometimes Nostalgia is thrown into
these TV shows and just in the same way
that reboots as a whole are done there's
a cash grab they will do it on a budget
because they know there will be some
interest they probably know the chances
are the season or movie or whatever will
never get past its first series or will
only ever you know maybe watch that once
by people and never again but they don't
care because they don't put a lot of
money into it in the first place and
they know they will get a return
sometimes Nostalgia is just a cash grab
just like the reboot as a whole and that
is when it's very very disappointing
because to be honest it happens more
than I'd like it happens a lot in fact
a lot
so
when a project is actually done from the
outset just for money it never works
when Nostalgia is thrown into a series
of a movie just do either make a bit of
Interest or again make a bit of money it
never works so I'm just arguing here
that just like the reboot Nostalgia is
great to a point
but when you go beyond that and you're
just trying to think about the cha-ching
it's embarrassing to watch it ruins TV
shows it ruins movies
and to be honest it never works
basically it's a bit like life if you do
something I'd agreed you're gonna get
stung in the backside so guys get into
the comments and tell me what you think
do you love these nostalgic moments or
do you actually think a lot of the time
they are just really
cynical grabs for attention or money and
actually you'd rather not do they work
sometimes but not others I'd love to
know any examples you can think of of
times where Nostalgia has worked in a TV
show or a movie like Picard to be honest
it did work on the whole but also I'd
love to know some examples that you
think of times when it's just been
cringe-worthy get to the comments and
tell me exactly what you're thinking if
you are new to the Channel please like
subscribe hit that Bell notification it
really helps us out and you'll never
miss any of our new videos also you can
go to patreon.com forward slash
Sidetrack where most of our new videos
appear first and for a small
contribution each month you can actually
support the channel and get to see the
videos without the adverts also you can
go to our new
focuscitrack.co.uk website your Sci-Fi
TV and movie website where stories from
most of our new videos will be appearing
that will give you a little bit more to
chew on
please go and check it out as always
please stay safe and I'll see you next
time
[Music]